so on action you can enter in land and
then one idea was was just a stocking
these are the lines here thank you okay
actually is it okay if I do Marcia Gay
Harden clients from hope you want to go
in that direction and actually I should
just stare at the camera and this looks
okay yeah you can do that and whenever
you is it okay if I just do Marcia Gay
Harden monologue from Pollak
I said sure whatever works
you want to know why we're not having a
baby Pollak because I'm you and you're
drinking yo you're need you need you
need and I'm not gonna bring a baby into
that Pollak thank you Albus Percival
Wulfric Brian Dumbledore yes I sure did
the others uh
do we did you guys film anyone else yet
we filmed Thomas Middleditch Nick
Offerman and Audrey Plaza okay I can go
did I get off manoah's whole night no of
course you didn't no too busy whittling
I'm reading the books it's making my
news I'm reading actually reading the
books that'd be a great chance really
well judging from the look on your faces
you guys don't have an answer for me so
I'm gonna have to wing this now well I
guess I'm gonna have to I guess I should
have flushed my preparation down the
toilet the way you did with the script
you guys he knows to play on kompis
first of all look look Brian Dumbledore
did the others day other did Nick
Offerman know the whole name no I didn't
know he did not know the whole name
maybe a little less time whittling more
time reading the books I don't know how
many canoes the world needs canula wood
shop I do this weird thing called
reading that's weird
I read the source material anyway happy
97th am I am I ready to play Albus
Percival Wulfric Brian Dumbledore I
believe yes I am I believe I am is
that's his entire name did the others
knows it did Nick Offerman know the
whole name
no no Nick Offerman didn't know the
whole name hmm
swear it maybe a little more time
reading JK Rowling's books and less time
whittling you know last time with a
woodshop activist I don't know how many
canoes the world needs I do this weird
thing where I read the source whatever
okay I'm just really quick before I go
what what kind of era are we talking
here this is around the time when
Dumbledore won the Barnabas Finkley
prize for exceptional spell casting
resist when he was the British youth
representative at the was in Gamma do we
know which one we're doing team he's
like a teenager so it's so we're just
gonna we'll wing the whole thing good
then I'll just maybe I'll just wing my
audition and it'll fit in right into
your kind of half-assed thing is this so
this is Patton Oswalt reading for Harry
Potter in the half assed movie here we
go I need a minute